we're joined by the Deputy Labour leader
Tom Watson mr. Watson a very good
morning to you good morning to you um
let's be clear about this rewind a year
I mean you were wrong weren't you when
you identified Jeremy Corbyn as posing
an existential threat to the Labour
Party you are absolutely wrong well
firstly your proposition is rug I didn't
I didn't say that he was an existential
threat but what I think has moved on
since the general election is Jeremy has
renewed authority to get 40% of the vote
in a general election I think gives him
the authority the power and the right to
make the reforms to our party that he
sees fit I hope the conference will back
in this week we've got some tough
discussions to have over the next few
days and I hope that will take us to
Wednesday when the United Conference
ready for his speech where he can
outline his vision for changing our
country and rewinding some of the
terrible things that always have done
in the last seven years in government
what convinced you was it genacore been
the man or was it the fact that he
performed rather better than everyone
expected the general election look
Jeremy is incredibly full of self
confidence and he went through that
general election with every commentator
in the land saying their labour wasn't
going to win he defied his critics and I
think that it's quited to the PLP as
critics I external to our party have
recognized that he has a great strength
of character and he convinced people in
that general election that you can do
you can put a proposition of hope not
fear to people and people respond to it
we've got three million new votes now
that is a totally changed terrain for us
and hopefully the conference this week
will recognise that and we will be able
to unite around him he'll be able to
outline his vision for the country in
his speech and then we'll it will take
us into the next period in Parliament
but just in your answer there I mean you
can see that there are divisions still
within the Labour Party well no there's
always divisions in all parties right
and it's a game of relativism if you
look at the papers today we started last
year's Labour conference with headlines
saying labour splits labor in labour
split down the middle actually if you
read the papers today it's all about the
government splits it's about Theresa May
and Boris Johnson and
Hammond given up on us from where we are
sitting there are members of the Labour
Party calling for a miracle to his own
well that is there are very small
numbers of people saying that that is
not the view of Jeremy or me or members
of the shadow camera we're terrific leap
ride of our full time members of staff
who delivered a very powerful general
election campaign in a very short notice
so those people that are demonstrating
against their stuff are not just
bullying they aren't wrong and NEMA
Nichol enjoys our full support still I
mean appropriately enough for them
spitting distance of where we are
sitting at the moment there are people
we don't only want to see you guilt
moved away from the post of deputy
leader but would rather not see you
within the party itself that doesn't
scream unity to me well again that's not
the view of the vast majority of our
five hundred seventy thousand members
look you're always going to get to
centers of political parties and
actually there's always personal
ambition and when you're in these
posters always people don't want your
job and one day someone will have this
job and I won't be the deputy leader but
that's actually irrelevant to the
millions of voters out there who want to
see change in this country it feels like
there are particles of hope in the air
and that is down to one man that said to
Jeremy Corbyn whom my social media this
morning was would you resign and I think
I know the answer to that question
already however the you called on Jeremy
Corbyn to live to his conscience when
there was the mass resignation from the
Shadow Cabinet I mean if there was a
similar expression of dissatisfaction at
from the party membership would you step
aside well I did actually say to a
parliamentary party that if I lost a
vote of confidence I would stand down
now there's a totally different context
that Jeremy did lose a vote though
confidence but he defied his critics and
he went back to the membership and then
we had a general election where he
defied his critics again I think he
deserves some space to outline his
vision for the country and to shape the
party in the direction he wants to take
it and I'm certainly going to give him
that this way but if Jeremy Corbyn is is
as you allege in control of the party
why have we seen these changes for
example two elections to the NEC the
changes that are written about you know
the threshold at which someone can
become a candidate the leadership jeremy
corbyn's in control why he's chained
well firstly let me say I realize for
your viewers me talking about the
details of the local party rule but
maybe a little bit dull but one of the
things we're discussing this week is to
give our members a bigger voice a bigger
say around our national executive
committee table that's actually
something that people in the party have
been arguing for many years in fact Tony
Blair argued for greater remember
representation on ABC it's taken Jeremy
Corbett to be able to convince our
unions that improve it that improving
the representation of our members on the
NEC is a good thing and I think we
should all and we were all united around
that when we discuss it on our anything
this week I hope the conference will
support him in that
and indeed on that on the leadership he
proposed a compromise position that one
in 10 Labour MPs would be able to
nominate a candidate for leader he was
gracious enough not to men not to
suggest that for the deputy leadership
so it took me to actually say well let's
bring the threshold down for the deputy
leadership as well so to the public but
it's an obsession of the party itself I
mean you may be yourself you've given an
interview to the pending a meal in which
you say you know there's a danger the
party could descend into internecine
warfare and arose about well no no no no
I didn't say that I said there is always
a danger that that could happen but I
one of what the scene this week is a
United Party and I think it will be you
know these changes enjoy my support
Jeremy's support the vast majority of
our members on the NEC and our unions
and I hope we'll have a good debate
about what a good sensible functioning
party who looks like how our members can
be greater participate in all our
structures in policymaking but
ultimately actually the real issues is
how are we going to address the concerns
of the British people that's even as I
started Jeremy and we will talk we will
get don't delve into policy in just a
moment but I mean it's not even as if
the changes to the rule birth are going
to stop there the Katie Clark review
which will be voted on you know this
time next year there includes for
example you know in training the ability
of party members to criticise Zionism
nothing could possibly go wrong with
that and it talks about putting
socialism back into clause 4 I mean the
battles are going to continue what well
hold on let me just say there are there
are the the conference will be decided
parameters for that review but I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna sort predict the
outcome you know there's half a million
people that are going to be involved in
this in their local parties our MPs our
counselors our MEP will play a role and
we want to make sure that this is we get
a series of sensible changes through the
mean that we're a professional modern
political party in the digital age last
on this then would you be happy to see
socialism get back into close form of
course I'm a social socialist I'd like
and if you know if our party members
want to change our rule book or a
constitution that's fine but I'm not
predicting the outcome of a law of a
consultation that hasn't even begun yet
okay I think last fear and this is what
my thoughts you in the chair filling for
Sophia but this once again trying to
think a little bit of clarity on the
party's position on brexit do you still
believe that we could be in the single
market after we leave the European Union
well we've said that the number one
issue for us in them as a negotiation
plan is to put this make this a jobs
first brexit and that means supporting
British workers and the interests of
businesses so we think that access to
the single market is the key thing so
that we can get our goods to market and
keep those workers in jobs that's why
that's why we called for a transitional
period we were very concerned that
Teresa may call in the election and the
first three rounds of talks failing as
well as meant that there was not enough
time to get a proper negotiated
settlement that's why we call for the
transition and what we said and when the
transition ends the key thing is that we
can still get tariff free access into
the European market and that's that is
that that should be an objective you
have said in the past that the remains
the potential for us to remain
permanently in the single market I mean
if we're talking about dividing lines
between did the labour and conservative
party at the moment maybe they have
adopted that the single market and
customs union through the transitional
period this at least we give you you
know
a point of development just to say on
that single bucket there's been a lot of
newspaper stories written about a single
sentence answer I gave in an interview
that I abused that that was actually
about gambling and there was a
multi-pronged questioning you get these
things and I said that the single market
may be an outcome of those negotiations
of course what I didn't get chance to
say is of course we're not the
negotiators that's the government right
and and instead to them to see what the
outcome is so of course it's possible
but the outcome we want to see is an
outcome that protects the interests of
British workers and that means access to
the access to those markets not
necessarily in in the form it takes at
the moment but we want to make sure we
could get tariff free access for our
goods and services but it is an
important point because the fundamental
dividing line it appears between hard
and soft brexit is to do with the single
market and we've had a variety of
responses in the mere three weeks that I
have been sitting in this year we have
had a collection of John Ashworth
telling me there's absolutely no chance
we could be in the single market you
know you of course have said that
there's a potential we could Jeremy
Corbyn is said no we're not and also
said yes we could well I hope I've
clarified about why I've said there's a
potential what I'm trying to say also of
course it is very difficult issues such
as slightly give the wrong nuance in an
interview I want to be clear to you that
our negotiating position should Pierce
Dharma be leading those negotiations
after an early general election will be
to put jobs in business first we want
transitional arrangements that retain
those characteristics of access in
single market the negotiated settlement
after that we want tariff free access
negotiated but of course that's time to
the negotiation so it's very hard to
give you the clarity you're looking for
because a we haven't started those
negotiations yet and B we're not the
negotiating team I can just tell you the
approach we would take to those
negotiations were we to be so 30 35 % of
labour supporters about auto the leaf
persuasion do you think they would be
satisfied if we had a deal post brexit
that looked vaguely similar to the
single market and with you know with the
kind of that and the concurrence of laws
and legislation between the UK and the
EU who would look we were with half a
million members we've gone we've also
got all different different views before
but there's a shadow cabinet
absolutely United that we respect the
decision of the British people in that
referendum we that's why we voted and
whipped the vote to trigger article 52
aprotic Parcher from the european union
but we were absolutely adamant that we
want the negotiations to be about the
interests of British workers and that
means supporting businesses too and you
know it's obviously members have
different views of how those
negotiations to take place but I can
assure you that Shadow Cabinet Jeremy
John McDonald kiyose Tom and me or all
our colleagues are absolutely United
around the position that Kirsten were
elucidated earlier in the summer we're
speaking today apprentice a little later
on in the show and we'll be picking up
on public sector P but let's be
absolutely clear as dawn public that
came from to me last week as things down
the Labour Party is not advocating and
above inflation pay rise for public
sector look we've got the we've got the
negotiating bodies that should agree
agree those pay rises and we've said
that in the we've said that we don't
support the paper and actually we said
that in our manifesto and we'd allocated
our sum of about four billion pounds to
make sure that those probably active
workers get adequate pay and that's the
work that's the approach we're going to
take to this but the four billion pounds
still represent a real terms of pay cut
when you've actually inflation we look
you've got it I mean the fitting is
bites this into negotiated sector by
sector the real principle is workers in
this country our public sector workers
up on lease our nurses I've had
effective pay cuts for seven years and
four if they're independent pay review
body sort of recommending above
inflation pay rises this year we think
it is cruel and arbitrary for the
government to apply that pay cut that's
why we brought it to the Parliament last
the week before last that's why the
government's costings don't have the
money to give an above inflation pay
rise the four billion pounds a year that
you've set aside doesn't include enough
money to give an above inflation pay
rise I mean it's I understand I
understand the point that you're linking
but as things stand it does seem a bit
rich for the Labour Party to have a pop
at the government for its essence
handing over a peacocks these problem
sector workers when your proposal would
do exactly this enough different I don't
I'm telling you that we don't want to
pay cap and we want though and we would
we would honor those independent pay
review bodies and we will find the money
to pay for that because we don't think
that public sector workers we think it
as didn't absolutely
dis benefits the system and people
leaving the service early with service
breakdowns and having to pay overtime
and all sorts of things that low morale
brings to an institution right and
that's why we're going to support our
public sector workers in that because
we're not saying just lift the lid we
say there's got to be there's got to be
productivity gains and those independent
review bodies are about negotiating the
adequate settlement but we're not going
to direct this from white or if we're in
government we think those work we've got
a we've got a process in place and
ministers shouldn't interfere with that
I understand that you and Len McCroskey
dog perhaps get on as well as you once
did but when it comes to the idea of of
striking without reaching the ballot
threshold what's your position was the
position of the party
look there's a lot of talk about this
I've actually received a letter from
them McCloskey the this week where he
says he accepts that in labor MPs will
be able you know aren't gonna support
calls for a legal strike action of
course we've got to stay within the law
but look at our manifesto we're going to
change our trade union laws because we
think they're unfair and that's the
point that Len Mycoskie was trying to
make the workers have been unfairly
penalized from organizing their affairs
to campaign for better pay and better
condition in the event I mean all
strangled would condemn well I look we
don't support a little Brit people
breaking that law and Len McCroskey
accepts that we don't want people to
break the law right we're Democrats we
set them but we go to change the world
so that trade unionists can have greater
rights because we think that corrodes
framework of laws is very unfair
particularly the last trade union ads
which we campaigned against in
Parliament and the way to deal with this
is to campaign against the government to
change their own laws and if they don't
change them elected Labour government
and will change the law to make sure
that our trade union laws affair Tom
Watson thank you very much for joining
us what you have a very enjoyable
project thank you very much you too